okay so thanks for the organizer and
frame here and also actually thanks for
joining us just introduce a little bit
about the content your network or you
know where original content circuits so
so that's exactly my my topic and in
probably order to that my talk might be
very different from all the remaining
talks because you probably don't see any
improve and even the claim probably just
like a very you know graphical okay so I
I guess it just a recap what we want to
do for you know starting this kind of
question so I guess the main question we
want or meant Raghavan to achieve is
that we want to find near-term corn
applications and we do see a lot of
ikana algorithm but even just you know
try to optimize the resources as soon as
still you know being out of reach at
least for maybe for the next decades or
so so but actually business is something
I copied directly from John per scale
stock that we should just use what we
have and you know try to use them in a
variation away and so you probably heard
the word allows like you know this is a
typical picture people call this hybrid
quantum classical optimizers but you'd
also have different names which is
imagine you have the quantum processors
which you know sometimes people call
this variational quantum circuits or
parameter quantum circuits or maybe like
Fitness ecologist answers so what we
really have is just quantum circuits
which each gate is apparently tried to
buy something like a real parameter and
like a typical gates are just like a
poly rotation gates with the parameter
being the angle and you try to solve
some problem you know through this kind
of interaction with the classical
optimizer
which you think it's very like you know
just a variational method in the
classical sense or maybe just like
measuring
problems because they also bearish you
know you try to think I have some way
you know depending on the feedback from
the quantum processor I can try to
optimize that and and actually there has
been a lot of starti along this line
this can be three extremely interesting
especially for the neck area and they're
allowed to impaired starting already but
of course you know so far because we
don't have the
machine so most of the starti app you
know they have limitation after the
simulation limit and indeed you know
there has been lot of proposal on this
line like a QA or vqe or like you know
sometimes we even call discontent your
networks so first I want you just help
you glance at you know this in a
slightly more details power to the
variation of calling circuits versus the
cascoon your networks and so on the left
side just a very very simple motive for
the feet forward a cascoon your networks
you have like layers so in your neurons
you have ways associative it's different
in nose and you just do some like
calculation which actually showed it a
bit more in detail later on so this is
what the classical one does and this is
you know on the right hand side this the
where is thumbkin circus so what you
should imagine is that you have like it
may be single layer like a single qubit
gates pair mate rides by the angles like
a road party rotation gates you have an
added layer of entangling gates and you
know so on and so forth and of course
you have input and output to both sides
both circuit is a variational your mom
try to sum some optimization problem or
for maybe some machine learning type
province so they're very similar to each
other so in that sense it's them to be
very promising because we see like you
know the classical in your life works
work pretty well in practice and so
that's actually you make people believe
this might be you know something can
give you something useful especially
they can be implemented on the near-term
so so what I want you to talk about is
Visser in this in a simple question and
so usually the way people treat you know
this similarity as a guaranteed then we
just think there's maybe some magic we
can directly use you know treating all
the techniques around a machine learning
as a black box we can just directly
apply and the specific question I'm
trying to think about can we have like
it being a better understanding you know
try to open the magic box for a like in
Russian earning try to see what you know
in what sense load technique can apply
and you know maybe over there be any
difference you know any changes we want
to make for quantity or net force the
other than classical ones you know in
order to try to answer that question
so here just like you know my very
personal perspective of the status of
the researcher we have for Casa
commercial earning and canta mission
earning think on the top line just the
consequence we have a very successful
empirical starti at a very very large
scale and you know the theoretical ones
actually it's trying to catch up but
still there's a sim should be some gap I
don't know how large it cannot be so and
Pradesh line there but like you know
it's really important for people
understand that but the quantum of her
quantum machine learning since this has
just started very recently the Surat ago
starting in empirical start is in in
both of their out during infancy so
they're not much you know started yet
and furthermore you know if we follow
the classical story and we try to do you
know empirical style first you know then
we observe a lot sense like maybe then
the serie can catch up we've faced
another difficulty for doing that for
content because even though we have a
very exciting progress for like you know
the quantum super mercy we have larger
machine but still they don't now seem to
be very easy to scale or very accessible
through all the researchers so so if you
want you doing pair Bastardi I think
maybe what you can do right now just
simulation right by yourself classical
simulation then you have some limitation
for doing that so a specific strategy
I'm trying to adapt here is that can we
somehow in lavage techniques from the
cirrhotic study of a classical machine
learning to help us understand better
about the quantum a machine learning in
a theoretical way of course it cannot
Soviet own answer all the questions but
maybe it can give you some hints or some
you know guidelines so when we have you
know because we do have like large
quantum machines so loads guideline can
help you to you know guided the
empirical study for quantum of course as
I said it cannot be so all the problems
but maybe you can tell you what are
impossible or maybe there's there some
you know you know permits and direction
you should have just followed so this is
the general methodology I want to follow
and if you think in that direction you
might want to ask what are the important
questions you know if you I want to
follow down a kind of massager that can
be answered yeah and I want you to just
showed we have seen a lot of you know
search a very exciting research on
landslide they try to ask the question
what are the new types of want an
application if you want to just use a
version of Conant circuits and I think
they're very important but somehow
there's some limitation for this kinda
line in the research you know the some
like you know routine for this kind you
know research they the map the
application to the version of quantum
circuits and they try to demonstrate
some like approval prints toss it can't
stop or principal simulation on small
size system and indeed it you know for a
loss research you see in the Pappy's
paper they work pretty well and then we
just hope it's girls okay so it seems
you know I think there's a really good
you know evidence but maybe it's a
slight pessimistic because we don't try
to think in whether thinking read these
scales so I so so what the question I
want to ask is that can we start the
training of those system can we maybe
get some handle on that should ask you
know just are together it can be trained
efficiently or maybe how you should
train this kind system yes pointed out
that the classical side Theory really
lacks yes
so would you expect on the content side
that's a good question I don't know I
mean I think it's so far we're not there
yet right so we we just try to sync with
in with a match the classical
understanding for content I don't have
explicit in my slides I just give some
examples along the line so I think you
know the training program is important
because it actually has a significant
practical impact because the number of
durations actually determined maybe
visibility or for your experiments and
oh so this is actually according to
something like and my personal
experience that I think maybe for
training quanta you mind is something
different from classic oh and of course
we still can just you know you know try
to use that the missile semester RG
people you just started the classic Oh a
training problem for example you can try
to think of you know think about or
start either landscape or your last
function
you know starting to behave like first
or second order method and we applied to
this first particular landscape and it
may be different strategy in primary
education or regularization so so what I
gonna you know you know top in the
remaining of the you know one that I
will show you just like two examples
along this line which I think there are
some interesting so I can say so so the
first example is actually a little
pessimistic but you also want to try to
see what you cannot do in the very
beginning so I'm basically trying to
show it like a training with you know
version of opponent circus engine or its
heart and this is not surprising on top
because you have tried you know train
this circuit by yourself you immediately
realize it's hard and but it should give
some aesthetic handles on that they're
not too many results so there has been
like a numerical results show in the
landscape for a certain you know up trip
function it is
of very non-convex and they're also
another problem we know that if you use
gradient based approach to train this
consistent if you use like a random
initialization of the system then very
easily you don't see any gradient so the
gradient vanishes zero and so this is
actually applied to star larger of the
sides of this kind of circuits and you
know of course I mean this does not
route if maybe for interesting classes
we do have some way to train this kind
system and especially for QA that's like
well starting topic there has been a lot
of research down in that direction I
think you know where he has talked me
which one are talking about you know
what you can do in in that direction and
I think there's some also other
interesting reservist I mean talking
about if your circuits extremely over
permit rights maybe there's some way you
can actually prove you can convert you
the good one and that what I gonna tell
you is that if some working progressive
a show in the context of supervised
learning there exist very reasonable
sitting and this where the last function
apply a deep aremy tries you know just
like D parameter varies and quantum
circuits you know we use a sample like
just the linear indeed data points you
can have like a two to the deed local
optimum for actually any integer natural
number D so what's different Beach you
know for our hours out you know from the
previous ones that this you can even
have people to very small size you know
quantum circuits so this says you know
the training problem is not just for
large one even for small ones you should
avoid this kind in no instance and I
think another nice sense that it
actually demonstrates some differential
between classical on your network and
quantum ones
yeah actually I'm gonna talk about that
so yeah let me just make sense of this
kind statement so so we first just you
know it's quick review revisit what
tsukasa-kun your network yes
so you're just imagine you have some
input and there's you know I have layers
of neurons and we're the me know the waw
and plus 1 just like representing the
parameter staff at each layer so and you
have input X you know there's some
output of Union have worked that's where
hatch so all the parameters definitely
you usually think about there's some
last function representing with their
curls there should be small with their
large there should be far away so
usually people can use like a square
loss and if you want to train this own
like n data points you just sum over all
those data ponds want to train and try
to optimize for the W so this you know
very simple type for neuron how to work
is color linear because it's evolution
just involving the multiplication of
loaves matrices you can make his slide
nonlinear actually this is important by
adding some like a nonlinear activation
function and the usually examples are
like radu and a sigmoid so what we know
classically it's interesting that if you
don't have any disk and now you know
linear parts like a rail do and in sick
knowledge we actually know even for like
a deepening yearnin divorce for this
type of a training there's no bad local
optimum so that means either you have a
local optima which is global one or you
have all of them to the critical ones
they're all Stata points so you have
some way to escape from those data
points and once you have activation
function like a long year out to ensure
function even for just like one new room
just like a one layer of sentence we're
like one single output you can construct
expression many local optimal so
actually this is a paper from like in
1995 so like a very very long time ago
so if you think about we know in a very
simple case just compared classical and
the content so this is you know like one
could be the version of quantum we were
just to have like a two poly rotation
gates and it doesn't have like the
nonlinear activation function like
classical ones
do you you think you know the quantum
want just like modified in this unitary
matrices and as long as we are encoding
an output you know we just use very
simple ones so there seems no non linear
part of your entire internet works so
you might ask one last question that
that they have a nice landscape
I think the conceptual message here is
that no Ino content have another way to
create a local optimal rather than you
know using the non e right you for an
activation function so here it comes
just to provide pictures so this is
something people use in the classical
construction they try to use a
non-linearity in a basic derivation
function and create the last function
something like this when you add in one
single point you know for one dimension
you're actually creating some like a bad
local minima like this and you can
actually keep doing that and we actually
showed this is not something possible
because we don't have this kind on your
ax T but we do have interference this is
especially because the way we apparently
tried our circuit is we have the each of
the eyes you know seed have for some
poly matrices so so what you see here
you could just imagine I have like a -
you know wave they're created by two
samples and we have some you know
interference of them because I sum them
up in my last function then I can create
some interference there I can create a
little bad local minimum and you can
actually have some way to scale this app
to multi parameters and creating special
many by something like a Dirac some
argument which I don't have time to talk
about yes so that's there's one example
to show in there indeed verge hard train
and the second example is that there is
some cases where you can actually you
know make the training smoother by
somehow change your loss function you
know make you know in a sense become
nice so this is the example in the
genetic model so here are just to give
you a very you know very introduction to
this classical ones so you probably
heard from the news like the deeper fake
you can generate some like human looking
pictures even though you did you know
it's it's already real and in the
vampire very poor method
do this it's use a genetical anniversary
networks some people call tag and return
discount moto and there has been
proposed that you use quantum for disc
on tasks to generate some like
distributions and why won't you do that
for the classical distribution you know
using contra generate that it's very
easy to see because conan circuits are
good at sampling so if you look at all
this content super mercy proposals
they're all sampling tasks that because
you know that's the domain we should
expect quantum can do better and you can
actually think about more about how
about we just now general ready in
quantitative I can just sorry I can
generate generally quantum data and you
know by definition the only quantity
circuits can generate content data so
you need a content to do that and
another regions that you might imagine
this you know this way you know quant
generating holiday I might have some
actually use just imagine you have some
like all know subjecting your
experiments you want to figure out
what's the structure of it you have some
like a you know very she knows you know
maybe from kind of matter physics you
know and said that you want to figure
out all the parameters so you have
almost anybody want you fit into the
model so that's exactly just in talking
about how to generate its quantum they'd
have from you know the experiments and
we actually show some at another it's a
part of the application of this electron
so I think importantly just remember all
this kind of you know saying they're
based on version of Conan circus so
there are likely to be implementable on
the near term and machines so again so
the aperture contribution for us is
still about training so we try to think
about the training program for this
quantity on komodo and this is because
training this kind of you know
generating mobile classically is
actually very dedicated and unstable and
tweening the quantum once could be an
even worse so this you know has been a
lot of a starting a most like an
empirical study try to you this can idea
to generate you know quantum gas but
they you know have very limited number
of qubits and parameter they can
actually show convergence so so we have
a paper appear in last year new reps so
we try to do this
you know in hope to scale the training
of this kind of model so this is the
water in the picture we put in our paper
so this shows that we can very similar
in this for like 8 cubits and for the HK
that can have like 200 gates so 200
gates and rotating gates and actually we
can do it a little bit more than that
and is we didn't put that into paper so
if you think about maybe your qubits are
noisy so we actually modal about the
experiment of noise from the iron trap
experiments and just try to put a
different layer of noise into the system
and try to see whether you're training
still be robust so this is the picture
we have for four cubits and why we do
this for four cubits because just direct
comparison from a paper from Christmas
group okay so so that's one contribution
we have there's another application
which is I'm surprising that we can use
this kind of you know generally modo to
compress on a circus so we actually have
example we show there's the 52 gauge
circuits can approximate a Kona
Hamiltonian simulation circuit over like
10,000 gates for using produc folder so
let us talk little bit about more that
so why this generator network can be
useful for compressing circuits so just
looking to what here does the idea is
that you want to generate some saying
that you cannot distinguish ground rail
stuff and if you just think about the
very simple in a fixed one input and
have the quantum circuit or have the
genetical network try to make them
indistinguishable we actually
approximate output for one input for
this particular circuit you can skill
that F you know try to catch in all the
information for all inputs by using the
charge I must if you guys are more for
them that's a more for the mapping
Quantum's circuits Chuck on stage so
what you lose in by doing that is that
you don't have no longer have the worst
case aren t you only have average
against guarantee so so what we achieve
is that we can actually use our system
to you know again Treena serve certain
gesek imagine we have this ideal gate
which is the
actor circuit and you want you also give
something very close and we have the
author put the fidelity in for this
particular one average on input the very
close one
but of course it you cannot guarantee
out in the worst case you know error
this is the worst case error is it's a
much larger than what you have from the
product one there but if you look at
this this is still useful because the
the noise being actually in the
near-term circuit isn't you know it's
actually about the same level so evenly
have very precise
you know circuits you have now give you
you know guarantee it give you something
good and actually you can try to use
this as in a scare down experimental
demonstration for like a physics
motivated quantum circuits and for
example you for you have some like you
know idea from physics you want to say
there's a certain have you know
simulation circuits and once used but I
don't know how to compress that into you
know the code ha you know the number of
case I'm allowed in my experiments you
can try this you know maybe you can give
you something good enough for your
experiments and what we actually did on
a technical side is that we try to use
the optimal transport norm to smooth
lots of the landscape of the training so
if you heard this term for the first
time so this has been well starting to
feel in mathematics it has to be used
classically the idea is that if you use
this kind norm
they actually introduce different kind
of topology on your like you know data
space somehow it just numerically
becomes smooth and stable so that's
actually our leaders name people call
Watson again classically we actually are
proposed a way to start this kind of
norm for quantum and we also implement
that in an efficient way into this
quantum game architecture so when I say
efficient is that it's everything in
principle if you give me pond and
computer to get me down in poly number
time and if you're like a physicist I
just want to point out there has been
started using this quanto primo
transport or start non equilibrium
physics okay so if you can just bear
with me just a few more minutes I want
you to just talk about something that
it's kind of an
bonus to the talk so I have talking
about yes no it's not your new unique
define saying I think there have been a
few different proposals depending on
your purpose because for hours proposal
you need to be you you need to be able
to implement efficiently so it's not
just the pure mathematical op no concept
because we want you to actually run and
use in the unknown so so there are many
different factors you need to favorite I
think I choose to us forest I know I
think we're the only one has consider
implementation so the other just pure
Mathematica proposals okay so sorry um
just get back to this so we have I have
talking about you know the training of
you know neuro networks or upon your end
the works but I want to also highlight
that there has been some you know I'm
not sure there's gonna be the real
parameter ship but we do see a new
programming paradigm people call
differentiable and a program language
and so if you haven't heard that it's
fine
that what it really gifts you and give
you truth you know to type of basic
sense one is that we might heard this
successful gradient based training and
you heard like it maybe you know Otto
grant or back propagation between you to
the current system so now you hope this
can be automatic down you don't need to
do that anymore
so this some you see if you've already
you know half saying tensorflow or pi
torch so there are another type of
science that maybe you can we create
something called a newer symbolic
application so you so neural network is
good in terms of you know it has been
very successful but it's really hard to
interpret you so what's the meaning of
that you know and why you can work so
the nearest symbolic application basic
asked question can we combine the
program features and the neural networks
to create some is for you know tasks are
used for applications so make sense that
needs more interpretable and actually
sometimes because you know some program
features were hard for neural network
chief it can give you some you know
match match tonight sir
you know feature even for the
applications so so we do have one work
just on on this line we try to think
about what we can do if we want to
define a differentiable quantum
programming language
it's actually motivated for after two
cents so again just following those two
concepts so for the first thing we do
want to use gradient based training for
accountant ones and we need to compute a
gradient at least so and we cannot
compute a gradient by classical means
because that's not scalable so oh so in
this paper up here gonna appear this
year PRI so we started how you can use
quanta have programs to compute a
gradients of any other quantum programs
so when it's a quantum core programs is
actually in general beyond we interest
the circus you can have a lot of program
features and we also demonstrated one
your symbolic applications of a quantum
where we have two version of quantum
circuits plus some like you know control
control measurement we use the average
so some carbon that is there's much much
more efficient than the previous you
know methods of course if you incurs
about like classical program language so
I think our you know proposed the
generates both differentiable ones the
properties once so you might have some
way to unify them and I think that's all
for my talk and if you're interested it
should play with our you know you know
tools we I think they're available kit
have thanks
[Applause]
so I think this is more like you want
you have quantum version of that right
so you have you're basically just want
to mix the quantum programs with
conjuring circles now make all
everything tunable everything become
paralyzed and they ask a new trend data
for some applications I didn't cover new
rotor machine but that's a you know we
only have a very simple case where we
have the control so we can do some like
intermediate measurement heating the
circus and the tell you what he wants to
next yeah but you know that could be an
interesting directions
so so so that's a good question as I
said I want to make the the facts of
lucky encoding and measurement out of
the picture so I use a very simple
measurement and and even you think use
account you know complicated measurement
is still a linear combination over your
coefficients because the measurement
self is not a parameter eyes so it does
now create like a nonlinear term yeah
yes so you mentioned that in the energy
landscape this quantum your networks we
still have lots of local minima can we
say something about whether they
generalize as well as global minima they
are just talking about the what are
those local well I mean in the classical
literature local Optima ought to perform
as good as yeah yes sir this is like so
I choose for our example we make sure
that won't happen so we really creates
that local Optima but you you could also
ask the question whether for like a
really practical instance with a lower
sense you're like I think there's were
like a super s you know local optima are
not we don't know an answer for that I
just say for our construction we make
sure they're bad
[Applause]